so
uh thank you for uh joining us today at
a drug discovery and development event
i just want to say a brief word or brief
words
to introduce dr chawan before he begins
his
quite fascinating presentation so after
completing his undergraduate degree in
physiology and biophysics at the
university
of toronto he spent five years at the
scripps institute
examining mechanisms of cell cycle and
checkpoint control
dna repair pathways and genomic
stability in both healthy and cancer
cells
he then returned to the department of
molecular genetics at the university of
toronto
where he earned his doctorate studying
additional mechanisms
responsible for control controlling
genomic stability
and implied and chromosome transmission
and whilst in academia he was the
recipient
of multiple governmental grants and has
authored over
20 peer-reviewed publications
so approximately five years ago dr
charwin co-founded synthex
and as its chief scientific officer
he has spearheaded the company's efforts
to examine
intracellular targets and these are
targets that have been selected based on
oncogene
addiction and synthetic lethality
related properties
and through through the development of
synthex's
torpedo and tornado platforms which he
will be mentioning in
his uh presentation
so these drug discovery and
developmental platforms
have uncovered peptide and macrocycle
candidates that
act respectively to disrupt
protein-to-protein interactions
or to degrade neo-substrate targets
using agilent's label-free excellence
real-time cell analysis instrumentation
to drive synthex's core screening
efforts
these platforms have fed the company's
therapeutic candidate
pipeline which is predominantly focused
on targets
that have um that have been previously
deemed to be
undruggable so dr chawan's talk today
which is entitled
using an unbiased drug discovery
platform to uncover a novel immunogenic
cell death
will provide an overview of synthex's
lead candidate
stx 100 from discovery through
through pre-clinical efforts and to the
cusp of
clinical development and with that
i will pass it over to dr chawan
hello everyone my name is charlie shawn
i'm the cso and co-founder
of syntax biotech startup in san
francisco
first i'd like to start with thanking
the organizers for the invitation
and i'd like to thank you all for tuning
in today
at syntax we are building a collection
of synthetic biology technologies to
enable us to produce
and functionally select potent compounds
that are capable of targets that are
thought to be or canonically
conventionally
assumed to be undruggable targets what i
mean by undruggable
are basically comp targets that have so
far eluded drug discovery approaches
these types of undruggable targets
include protein-protein interactions
protein dna interactions protein rna
interactions like transcription factors
or splicing factors
as well as low-specificity enzymes like
phosphatases nucleuses
esterases in general and the
conventional wisdom in the field is that
currently these types of targets are
undruggable are out of reach because the
available libraries of chemical
compounds that we have our
at our disposal are not complex enough
to be able to
contain compounds that can efficiently
engage these targets these difficult and
challenging targets
and the other thing is that even if we
were to overcome that limitation
of lack of complexity if you were to
achieve some somehow
this level of complexity the labor
intensive nature of the screening
approaches required for
screening for these types of activities
is quite prohibitive so what we've done
at syntax is basically we've decided to
rely on the power of synthetic biology
to specifically address these two
challenging tasks
and what we've done to address these
specific two things
first of all to address the question of
labor-intensive
screening approaches we've built a
synthetic set of synthetic circuits that
are proprietary to us
and we utilize these circuits to allow
us to screen for complex biological
functions
uh in a facile and cost effective way
and on top of the logic circuits that
were built in our
platform we actually include the ability
to
make a very complex library of over 10
billion different compounds
that are actually being made inside the
cells of the ribosome
so we combine these two innovations
in one of our platforms that we call
torpedo in order to be able to identify
factors or compounds
that can disrupt intercellular protein
protein interactions
on the other hand with the tornado
platform we rely on these
two same two innovations but in the case
of tornado instead the question is not
can we
disrupt two protein proteins from
interacting with each other but rather
can we bridge a ubiquitin e3 ligase to a
particular target of our choice of our
interest
in such a way that the target now
becomes a new substrate for the e3
ericton ligase and the ligase
ubiquitinates it
and subsequently targets it to the
proteasome for it to be
degraded by the ubiquitin proteasome
system
and the programs in our company that
rely on torpedo right now are two
programs around 51 and oncogenic k-ros
programs rat 51 i'll
talk about in much more details in a
second uh
keras would be it would be beyond the
scope of uh
this talk and we do have another couple
of programs that rely
on the tornado technology so
moving on to a rad 51 in
this target basically i've been
interested
in for more than 15 years now it
interests them
originally from these foundational
publications that came out from the
holiday and alan ashworth labs in the uk
in 2005.
in these publications the two labs
reported that they've discovered the
fact that
uh breast cancer cell cancer cells
that are mutated in the braca one or
bracha two genes
are particularly sensitive to inhibition
of an enzyme that's known as polyadp
ribose polymerase or shortened
for part and
what they've what they found is you
could either genetically ablate by
knockout
the part gene and then cause death of
these bracha mutated
cancer cells or if you use a small
molecule inhibitor of the
parp enzyme you cause you specifically
cause
death of the brachial mutated cancer
cells but not of healthy
braca wild-type or broca heterozygous
cancer cells intact cells
and fast forward for less than 10 years
a bunch of pharma companies got these
types of small molecule compounds in
target part
fda approved and there we now have four
of them
in the clinic that are fda approved in
in
for multiple indications uh where the
cancer is
have a bracha one mutation or
brachiature mutation or
mutations in any of the components that
are co-factors of the braca
pathway genes however as is always the
case with
precision medicine this has been one of
the recent triumphs of precision
medicine
but there's always caveats and the
caveat here in this particular case
obviously is uh
that resistances do arise in different
ways
we knew about several ways how
resistance could arise in the pathway
because of mouse models of breast cancer
and bracha mutations
there are many different approaches
different ways how
cancer cells in the mice or in tissue
culture end up
becoming resistant to park inhibitors
cancer cells that carry broccoli
mutations
uh but in the clinic on top of all these
different
approach these different paths
that resistance could arise in the
clinic there are two other
one other key factor that seems to be
quite common and
one of the easier ones to attain and
that is the up regulation of a protein
called
51 so it is
in in even before administration of
parp inhibitors people had noticed some
multiple scientists have noticed that
in bracket-mutated cancers there is high
upregulation of the rad51 gene
and that allow that gives fitness to the
brain mutated cells
and more recently after inhibitors got
into the clinic
uh studies have uncovered from among
some of the
pipe resistant uh patients
a group of patients that down regulate a
protein called the mi1 which is in
ubiquinone ligase that causes
degradation of the rad51 protein
so one could either a cancer cell could
either upregulate the transcription of
rat-51 or
cause the stabilization of the raton
protein by inhibiting its degrading
factor
become resistant to carbon inhibitors
and some cancer cells might rely on both
approaches
or even more further stabilization by
possessing further post sensational
modifications and that phenomenon of
upregulation or
hyperstabilization of rat-51 is actually
not unique to pipe inhibitors or to
braca
mutated cancers or to
cancers that have been subjected to a
selective pressure like
with a chemo drug but rather it's a very
common phenomenon that happens quite
often
in in cancers it's been reported in in
metastatic breast cancer in prostate
cancer in
pancreatic cancers and a lot of
hematological cancers it's a very common
occurrence just like it's almost
analogous to the occurrence of having
telomerase being
re-induced in the cancers relative to
adult tissue
and the other thing about 51 that is
very exciting to us is that it is very
lowly expressed in
adult healthy tissue so you can see here
this is a northern blood showing
around 51 and one of its cofactors the
mrna levels of them
and you can see here that in most adult
tissues except for the
male germline testes there is no
detectable levels of the rational
protein and
uh obviously in the male germ line it's
it's
expected to see right 51 direction is a
recombination protein amoled
discrimination protein
and in the male germ line there's always
a combination happening
during spermatogenesis so one would
expect to see
high levels of ratato in there but
otherwise it is a very lowly expressed
protein
in healthy tissue however in cancer
tissues in this case done
below here i'm pointing out to multiple
different cholinergic carcinoma liver
cancer
cell lines that have very high levels of
t1
yet the normal tissues in comparison
have no detectable electrode at this
level
and that's not restricted to the mrna we
see that
in the lab also with many many different
cancer cell lines
uh all of them have detective levels of
the rad51 protein this is a western blot
with
showing the rational protein here uh
however primary cells
that are not transformed not
immortalized have very low levels of
ration barely detectable at all
however whenever these primary cells
actually do get immortalized
and become closer to becoming cancer
they start showing higher levels
of around 51. and this feature of
ratatouille being so
uniquely expressed or so strongly
expressed in cancer cells relative to
healthy cells
has been exploited in gene therapy type
approaches
where people have done two different
things one to
link a visualization reporter
to a rat 51 promoter in order to mark
the cancer cells and visualize them in a
an organism like in a mouse and the
other approach was to drive
a toxin using the rat proteome promoter
and delivering that toxin into
systemically
uh administering it to a mouse for
example and seeing that only the tumors
shrink and
there's no adverse effects of killing of
general cells healthy adult cells in the
most
and like you can see here in these uh
mouse images the the mice that had
tumors implanted in them light up
whenever they get given this uh
transgene luciferase attrition driven
luciferase transgene the mice that did
not have
tumors implanted in them do not light up
at all there is no particular
tissue or compartment in a healthy
animal that
would have active expression of
radiation to the level that
would be visible by imaging systems
so given this uniqueness of rat51
expression and abundance to cancer cells
we thought besides the fact that it's a
way how cancer cells
gain resistance against spark inhibitors
it could be a good target that allows us
to get selectivity
for uh the cancer cells over healthy
cells and
when we are treating a tumor and
uh in addition to that aspect of
rat 51 being enriched in in
expression-wise and tumors
there's one other thing about tumors
that we tend to forget
and that is tumors as they are dividing
very fast
in an uncontrolled and unqc'd way they
end up
accumulating a lot of genomic
instability in their dna and
and that genomic incivility leads to
fragments of dna
being extruded out of the nucleus into
the cytoplasm
and under normal condition dna that is
in the cytoplasm
activates innate immune responses
because
we are designed to ourselves are
designed to think that
any type of foreign dna that's residing
in the cytoplasm and any type of dna is
that in cytoplasm is going to be a
foreign origin like a
an adenovirus or some other dna based
virus that came to attack
our cells and we should mount an immune
response against it
so in cancer cells because there's a lot
of dna that's not just in the nucleus
but also in the
cytoplasm usually you'd think that these
cancer cells would be mounting
constant inflammatory type responses uh
because of that xdna activating the
native immune response in them
however that doesn't happen because of
rat51 rad51 has the ability to code this
single sun dna forms a filament around
it
and prevents it from engaging the
innate immune response dna sensing
machinery
uh so just that yeah i mean this is a
summary about
what we know about the actual protein at
the biochemical level it's an atpase
it hydrolyzes atp and it binds it and
hydrolyzes it and
controls its activity that way uh it
forms a nuclear filament around single
sun dna just like actin forms a filament
in our cytoskeleton or microtubule same
thing
it's very similar to these types of
motor proteins
and it is the atp bound form of
rat 51 that is the active polymer
forming form that binds to single cell
dna
and this form specifically binds to
single stand dna when it's in the
calcium
uh binding form so the calcium bond form
of the
triphosphate uh state of the atpase
ratio 51 does get gloated on dna via the
braca
ii protein and that's why over
expressing it gravity basically
catalyzed the loading catalyzes the
loading of that 51 onto dna
and that's why whenever there's a
brachial mutation you can
bypass that mutation by having high
levels of ration compensating for the
weak catalysis return can also bind
double sin dna it actually binds
single and double sun dna basically at
the junctions particularly
get slowly as i said by bracket2 it has
intrinsic gtps activity and
it controls itself just like many other
types of nucleotide
uh hydrolyzing proteins like gtpases
like keras and others
they they auto regulate themselves by
hydrolyzing the atp and converting it to
adp
and that adp bound form in this
particular case for r51 is the inactive
form
that is incapable of productively
engaging single sound dna
we are not the only people who actually
thought about ratatouille as being a
good target there has been multiple
attempts by multiple different labs
uh academic labs and industrial labs uh
trying to find compounds that engage
right 51.
a lot of attempts have gone after its
single standing a mining affinity
activity others have went after its
double standing irani activity and
uh some attempts have gone after
its ability to form polymers basically
to break its own
uh polymerization potential the
interactions between two rational
protons
from all these attempts there is only
one compound that ended up going to the
clinic
and that's psychiatric therapeutics
compound citaris in boston
they just went into the clinic just a
few months ago
and their compound basically works in a
bit of an unclear way but what is known
is that it
prevents rat51 from migrating to sites
of dna damage where it needs to act
and promote repair um
and yeah that's uh i've just lighted up
by the clinical trial that satire is
currently undertaking so
given all that precedence and the lack
of success with all these different
approaches
we decided to take a little bit of a
different approach at syntax
especially relying on the fact that we
can we can have the ability to break
protein protein interactions in a very
good and efficient way
and one of the things that
caught our attention from the gene
expression profiling that was done
a while back was that one of the common
things that happened with bracket
mutated cancers is the obligation of
route 51
but the upregulation of rat51 does not
happen in a void does not happen on its
own
it tends to get upregulated along with
several other
coeffectors or effector proteins that
help it work
and while it has many other effectors
several
co-players working with it particularly
rat54
and rad51 ap1 are the two genes that get
co-op regulated whenever rad421 gets
upregulated in bracket mutated cancer is
so we thought maybe there is something
particular about the interaction of
ratatouille with these particular
proteins
that is especially for cancers in
general and particularly cancers that
are brachammuted
or that have uh been exposed to pipe
inhibitors
so our approach basically uh
boils down to can we break the rats of
t1
rats to an ap1 interaction and if we can
what sort of phenotype can we get
in inhibition of the natural activity
can we get out of that
so we relied on our torpedo platform
to discover the protein protein
interactions of that 51 return
ap1 protein point interaction
and uh it those types of screens yielded
a group several hits we
underwent a prolonged uh
effort to perform sar
and understand the mechanism of how
these compounds are acting
on rat 51 and how can we improve their
pharmacokinetic properties
and ended up with a very stable
derivative
of one of our hits that we biochemically
stabilized
and look forward to biochemical
studies and to tissue culture studies
and in vivo
uh studies and i'm going to be
presenting some of this work
right now uh so starting with just
binding that
one of these hits uh that we found is
uh an amino acid peptide came out
straight out of the torpedo platform
uh it binds in single digit nanomolar
affinity to r51 very
good binder uh we've managed the final
compound that
was the result of our sar campaign uh is
a
hyper stabilized d amino acid uh
peptidonic
that's very stable yet retains the same
level of affinity to that 51
as the initial starting uh tool compound
that came out of the screen
and one of the nice things that we've
managed to find is a
single substitution version of the
peptide
that completely loses its ability to
write it to bind ratified and
this version of the compound uh has
become
quite crucial for our studies
subsequently in order for us to know
that
uh the phenotypes and the effects we're
seeing are on target
whenever we use the compound that cannot
bind r51 we don't usually see any of the
effects we see with this compound
so to start with after we got the stable
compound wanted to see whether it's
being able to enter cells again
peptides are have a bit of a bad
reputation about being
not being able to get into cells very
easily but we were
lucky and fortunate in uh this
particular set of peptides
that they uh were pretty self-permeable
on their own so this in in this panel
here i'm showing
a fitzy labeled version of the active
peptide as well as the inactive
scx-100m is the inactive one uh
both peptides enter cells and you can
see we can see them green inside the
cells
the active peptide binds that 51
enriches in the nucleus
and that's that makes sense because
that's where right 51 is
the inactive peptide enters the cells
but it remains pan cellular
doesn't actually go into the nucleus and
that also makes sense if there isn't
much
right 51 in the cytoplasm most of it is
in nucleus
we wouldn't expect to see the peptide
going into the nucleus
and then as we started to look at the
cells and and
characterize what happens to the cells
when they're exposed to they get exposed
uh to our compounds one thing
that was very peculiar jumped at us very
early on and
that is that quite early after treatment
of cancer cells with our compound
we do see a very strange
hypercondensation of chromatin
and the nuclei become much much more
hyper condensed
as well as the general integrity of the
cytoskeleton of the cells get
compromised there's a catastrophic
uh destruction or depolymerization of
most of the microtubule networks
and we end up with cells that look
pretty sad and the nuclei
are hyper condensed that's specific
to the active peptide when we treat the
cells with the inactive version of the
peptide
we don't see any of these phenomena and
again i
want to point out that this this
phenomenon happens within minutes
this is these pictures were taken 30
minutes
after exposure to the compound but we do
already see
phenomena like features and phenomena
like these in the cells
as quickly as two or three minutes after
exposure to the
peptide and because it was
such a fast phenomenon we decided to
rely on a
measurement cell cell viability
measurement approach that can
take very very high resolution time wise
uh time point detected definite time
points for viability
in our systems we initially tried a few
of the imaging
systems while they they're great for
seeing what's happening to the cells
they're a bit too slow for a phenomenon
that's happening in the level of seconds
and minutes
uh on the other hand uh accelerations
from asea was a perfect tool for
a perfect instrument for us to be able
to test uh
and and understand further what's
happening when our compound is
administered to cells
but you can see here basically i'm
showing you ssp25 these are
liver cancer cells that got treated with
the active peptide in red
and there's a very quick precipitous
loss of cell index and impedance
uh which is what the excellence is
measuring
however treatment with the inactive
peptide
does not cause any sort of uh decrease
in impedance
towards the cells and mock treatment
with pbs
doesn't cause any of that either so one
question here that always arises with
impedance measurements is that
oh what if this is not actual death but
rather
the cells just underwent some sort of a
morphological change that
changed their level their ability to
impede the current uh in the well
and that's why you're seeing this
precipitous impedance this is not death
this is just
morphology reflecting morphological
changes so in order to
convince ourselves that this is not
actually just morphology but
but a point of no return type of
commitment
to loss of life uh we went back to
microscopy
and uh we wanted to know whether
treatment of cells that hyper that
overproduced right 51 like cancer cells
versus cells that do not overproduce
afriton like primary cells
how do they respond when we treat them
to the type and what do they look like
when they get exposed to the peptide
uh and as you can see with these phase
images the liver cancer cells assume
within
five minutes of being exposed to the
compound they get these
big bubbles uh forming the whole cell
coalesces around the nucleus
and then the cell the cellular volume
forms
these big bubbles that extrude out from
one corner usually
in 10 minutes and the cells are looking
very very sad
and that goes on for basically
and they never recover from it
fibroblasts on the other hand
primary cells they get exposed to the
peptide in this case
compound and they don't mind it the
least bit
you can look at them five minutes 10
minutes half an hour
24 hours later and they're just fine and
happy
so that convinced us that what we're
seeing
is some sort of a programmed mechanism
not
not just like oh drug is just like
bleach it's just killing cells
willingly without any sort of
selectivity first and
uh it's killing cells in not in any
particular
programmed way cells die in different
ways it wasn't the case
every different cancer cell we tried
more than 30 different cancer types
and every single cancer type that got
exposed to our peptide
cancer cell type ends up dying with the
same type of morphological features
the dna coalesces inside the nucleus and
hyper condenses
most of the cell material condenses
around the nucleus
and then there's this strange bubble
bubbling that happens
in a very short period of time that's
not similar to blebbing
that or necrotic type blebbing or
blubbing that is seen in
apoptotic cells let alone the fact that
it happens so much
much faster than what the type of
bubbling that happens
in apoptotic or necrotically dying cells
and like this is just an image of
typical image of
how these bubbles would look that the
cells the cell content coalesces and
then
cells extrude these bubbles out and
that's happening within 5-15 minutes
after exposure
to the peptide so the first question was
maybe what we're doing is base
is uh the peptide is somehow
compromising the integrity of the
membrane of these cells
and that's causing them to somehow lose
membrane potential and and cause sort of
osmotic osmotic imbalance that's causing
this massive bubbling to happen
so in order to know whether the
integrity of the cell membrane has been
compromised at all
we decided to rely on the lactate
dehydrogenase
assay and likely dehydrogenase is a
cytoplasmic enzyme
uh it's a big protein so it doesn't it's
not passively diffusing across the
membrane
uh if you're if we take uh media or
supernatants from outside of the cells
and assay them for likely dehydrogenase
activity we shouldn't see any
because the enzyme is inside the cells
as long as the cells are intact they're
not releasing it to the outside there
shouldn't be any activity
but if we lyse the cells with like
triton any typical lytic agent
uh detergent of some sort then we're
lysing the cells open
and the enzyme gets outside into the
media and when we measure it like the
hydrogenated activity
in the media we can see we can see very
measurable easy activity
so the control here is triton the lysis
titan x
lysis buffer and the lysis agent on the
other hand if we treat cells with stx
100 there is no detectable ldh being
released
into the outside of the cells and what
was
shocking and impressive to us was that
when we looked at these cells
24 hours later we actually we still
couldn't detect any lactate dehydrators
activity
so they were still retaining integrity
of the membrane in such a way that was
not causing proteins
to leak outside of the cells and but
then
if we were to treat those cells now with
a
detergent triton then we end up with
release of that likely dehydrogenase
into the media so the cells had died or
had committed to a point of no return
five minutes after exposure to the
compound
yet 24 hours later they had retained the
enzymes inside the cells in a functional
active state so
there's uh it's unlikely that the ph is
massively changing in these cells or
there's huge differences in chemical
nature that would cause
uh aggregation or
or instability of a lot of proteins
inside the
the dying cells the dead cells uh
so then it we concluded that it's not
some sort of general membrane
destabilization then
even though again the morphology doesn't
correlate with
what types of morphology seen with
canonical cell death like
apoptosis or necrosis we still wanted to
make sure that
the machinery that's involved in these
types of cell death
is not involved either in this new
mechanism of death that we've uncovered
and so we went first for uh for
nephrosatin which is a kinase inhibitor
that would block
processes of necrotosis here what i'm
showing in
uh grain are cells that were treated uh
with sdx this is the impedance
measurement
with the excellence uh they get treated
with scx-100
they quickly die when they are treated
with necrostat and they don't show much
death
at these time points uh if we treat them
with a compound
along with necro 7 s6 100 along with
necrosatin
no uh abrogation of the cell death uh is
seen we don't rescue that killing that's
caused by
uh cx100 so clearly rip kinase and their
kinase pathway is not involved in the
stx mediated cell death
similarly when we use a pan caspase
inhibitor
again combining sx100 with the caspase
inhibitor here in blue does not
alleviate in any way the killing of the
cells that
of the cancer cells that the sx-100 does
so to cut a long story short
after a whole bunch of analyses we
concluded that it's
the process of cell cancer cell deaths
that we don't cover it
is space independent of kinase
independent it's just gene
it's not just general membrane uh
decibilization or lysis
it's not for ptosis not autophagy and
not mitophagy
and that left us scratching our heads
thinking what is happening here like
wait
this is clearly an on target mechanism
that is specific to cancer cells
yet it's a new phenomenon that hasn't
been to the best of our knowledge
reported in the literature and uh so we
decided to go back to the biochemistry
of ratatouille and try to understand
exactly what could be causing this
knowing what we know about
ratifiance activity so first uh one of
the peculiar things that
that caught our attention during our sar
campaign
is that the compounds that we've
discovered in our screen bind very well
to ratatouille in the single-digit
nanomolar range
but they're completely incapable of
binding
to the homologues of ratification
orthologs of ratatouille
in many yeasts including budding east
the bunnings economic service and
globalizes like this
so that was particularly peculiar for us
because
one thing along the same lines that was
noted a few years ago was the fact that
1951 relies on calcium for its activity
yet the yeast right 51 homolog does not
rely on
to end calcium for its activity it
rather uses magnesium for activity
and around 51 is capable of using
magnesium
however and that's the the divine cation
that actually helps it stimulates its
atpase activity it helps it
hydrolyze the gamma phosphate to uh to
make adp
out of it and what has been shown is
that when
magnesium is added along with calcium
calcium actually
competes with magnesium and prevents the
hp activity of
uh return and if you recall at the
beginning what i was
talking about right from is that it
forms this nuclear filament iron dna
that codes single sun dna
and that nuclear filament is dependent
on the atp bound state of rad51
so in that sense it's also dependent on
being calcium bond as opposed to
magnesium bond
because if if right 51 is magnesium and
it's going to hydrolyze that atp
and it's going to fall off of the d
nucleate and fall off of the single sun
dna
so it is very important for rotation to
be able to bind to
calcium in human cells the human rights
of young protein
yet not the yeast protein and our
peptides
our compounds that we discovered also
bind only to the human protein
but not to the yeast protein
and uh what we also know about actually
one
uh about the activity of our peptide on
natural tumor is that it is assisting in
atp
activity in atp hydrolysis so
the thought was it when we actually
treat
these cells with our peptide the peptide
goes into the cell the compound goes
into the cell
it engages rhetoric stimulates its
atpase activity
and in spite of the presence of the
calcium ion
and because of the stimulation of the
atps activity the polymer
d polymerizes falls off and now uh
rather than is in the adp bound state it
no longer needs calcium and
it releases calcium very quickly so the
big question is that
is that what that we posed was okay so
if
if our peptide is causing calcium to
fall off of the pool of rat 51 that's
present in the cancer cells
much more abundantly than healthy cells
is that
spike in calcium what might be causing
these cancer cells
to die and
that was the thought in our minds
because calcium is
particularly tightly controlled in its
abundance inside the sun's concentration
inside the cell where it's free the free
the concentration of free calcium inside
the cell is around
50 to 100 nanomolar if resting state in
the cell
it is around 2 millimolar outside the
cell so there is over
10 000 x gradient across the membrane
there's so much
active processes that make sure that
calcium is not coming from the inside
from the outside of the cell to the
inside
uh given how big of a gradient there is
there magnesium on the other hand is
much more abundant inside the cell
yet there is not much of a gradient
between the inside and the outside of
the cell
uh so it was very peculiar to us as to
like how could it be that
rad 51 inside a human cell is utilizing
calcium
rather than magnesium even though
there's like 10 000 times more
of the magnesium cation than the calcium
cation in the cell there must be
something
active about this process and and
there's a
mechanism by which the filament is
making sure that it stays in the calcium
bond state
and if the filament is abundant in the
cancer cells it is acting as a sponge
that is soaking up a lot of calcium
within it
uh what we know about rat 51 abundance
in
urine fibroembryonic fibroblast is that
it is in the micro molar range in the
cancer cells it's presumed to be even
higher than that
so if if our peptide is capable of
engaging the pool of rat 51 in a fast
manner
stimulating atp hydraulics and releasing
all that calcium all at once
we will get at least a 10x maybe even a
bigger 20x
50x sudden surge in calcium
concentration inside these cells
and that has been our working hypothesis
at the beginning that uh
the cancer cells are dying because we
are overpowering the
cancer cells buffering calcium buffering
capacity with this
huge surge of calcium so in order to
test that
we first check to see if whether there
is an
actual calcium spike that happens in the
cells that get
exposed to our compound and uh
gratifyingly enough that's exactly what
we see
here we're using the fluid two am
calcium sensing dye
and right at this exact same time that
we start seeing this
having problems we see a very clear
increase
in intracellular calcium levels that and
it's always
very consistent where we see the calcium
seemingly
arising from the perinuclear region
somewhere around the er
and it emanates from there and fills up
the whole cell within 10 minutes
uh and so if that calcium spike was
causative rather than an effect one of
the
many effects of the death one would
expect that
if it is the cause then quenching that
calcium and
mopping it up out of the cell again
would be a
one way how one could be able to rescue
these cells from being killed by a
peptide
and that's exactly what we see when we
rely on
when we use baptim which is an
intracellular calcium chelator
uh obviously chelating intercellular
cancer is going to be toxic on its own
we see here the impedance being
not as good as mark treatment with pbs
the scx-100 kills the cells very quickly
the beautiful thing is treatment of the
cells along with the peptide along with
a calcium chelator we get full
suppression of that killing
uh that we see so we know now that it is
a calcium dependent killing process and
that's the only
agent that we found that is capable of
suppressing the cell
cancer cell death that's induced by
stx100 we've also
i like to note here that we've also
tried chelating calcium on the outside
of the cells with
egta or cell impermeable calcium
chelators
in treatment with those types of factors
do not at all prevent decline by a 6100
so we do know that the pool of calcium
that is
spiking up is not coming from the
outside of the cell it's actually coming
from intracellular source inside
the cell and that
phenomenon of calcium surge got us very
very excited
because a few years ago now uh
work from the cromer and zit vocal lab
in in france
uh to try to understand uh how
mechanisms of immunogenic cell death
arise and what are
the compounds that can induce an
immunogenic inflammatory state around in
the tumor cells
and cause engagement of immune system in
those types of
uh studies that they've done in the
screens that they've performed
the strongest agent that they've
uncovered that can do this
is a
set of compounds that are known as
cardiac aminoglycosides
and these compounds block sodium
potassium
pumps in the cell membrane of the of
cells cancer cells in that case
and by blocking those pumps it causes
imbalance in the ionic potential across
the membrane
and that leads to a very sudden influx
of extracellular calcium into the cell
and the surge of calcium inside the cell
causes a strong endoplasmic reticulum
type stress
upr type response er stress response
and this er stress response leads to the
presentation of
immunogenic molecular patterns on the
surface of cancer cells
and those molecular patterns are
recognized by the immune system by
macrophages
in the dendritic cells and professional
antigen presenting cells
and helps them in presenting the new
antigens and antigens from the tumors
to the immune system so we wanted to
know whether
when we're killing our cancer cells so
quickly with our stx100 compound
are we in the process not just killing
them but also making them present
immunogenic markers on the surface that
could help the immune system
recognize them even faster and quicker
and to clear them
and in order to test that we first
checked for one of these hallmarks of
immunogenics and tests
a presentation of the cal reticulum
protein on the surface of the
cells territorial is a protein that's
usually found in the endoplasmic
reticulum it's not on the outside of the
cells
however when cells are dying in an
immunogenic fashion they do present
cellular tickling on their surface and
cariticulin is
a marker on the surface of cells
that is known as an eat me marker it
basically
stimulates macrophage macrophages and
other phagocytic cells like
dendritic cells to phagocytize any
cell that is presenting cardiac on its
surface
and it's so the phenomenon that we see
with stx100
is not limited to choleticon we see also
relocalization of hmgb1 which is a
nuclear protein
that binds to dna from the nuclear frame
nucleus where it forms usually foci in
healthy cells
to the pericytoplasmic region uh
all over the cell so you can see it here
in mock treated cells the
uh foci of hmgb1 are very distinct and
clear
and in science stated cells there is no
more fossil in the nucleus
it's all spread out all over the sun and
this is one of the hallmarks of
emergence of death as well
and this phenomenon happens very very
quickly
exactly the same time frame uh that the
cell death is happening the reversible
cell death that we see with
the excellence impedance sharp drop-off
in the impedance within five minutes
the relocalization has already happened
by ten minutes it's reached its maximum
um and so now we know that stx100 is
killing cancer cells specifically in a
healthy cells
by exploiting that
cancer-specific massive pool of rat 51
that's
acting as a calcium sponge it engages
that pool releases all that calcium
causes the calcium surge
the calcium surge kills the cells but
also not just kills the cells
it causes them to present uh immunogenic
markers on their surface
and those immunogenic markers are known
to help engage the immune system
including dying cells or compromised
cells
and because of all these exciting
factors
that we see in tissue culture we decided
to now
move on and see what do we see in a
living animal
that gets exposed to scx-100 and that
has a tumor growing and gets exposed to
s6100
and quite gratifyingly when we moved on
to test
this in a immune proficient type of uh
cancer model it's in genetic model cd26
colon cancer
in bulb c mice uh it's a very aggressive
tumor these are tumors
these are mice that were treated just
mock treated with pbs
the tumor very quickly gets to volumes
thousands of millimeters cubed of volume
within a couple of weeks
uh the mice that had been implanted with
the tumor
and then nine days later when the tumor
got to around 100 millimeters cubed
they got treated single with a single
dose of sdx 100 500 400 micrograms of
scx-100 inter-tumorally uh
50 3 out of 6 mice fully absorbed their
tumor and got fully cured
and that cure was uh long-lasting
they never researched uh and had a tumor
regrowth
uh these tumors as we followed them uh
if we were to have used a higher dose of
scx-100 again single treatment but
doubled the dose to 800 micrograms five
out of six and one ninety percent of the
tumors
uh got fully uh uh completely destroyed
and the tumor and then the
mice were fully cured uh this type of
cancer
again is extremely harsh and
one of the hallmarks of like the
superstar compounds
anti-cancer agents that are in the
clinic now are
anti-pd1 and anticipate4 antibody
therapies uh katruda and optivo
in this case the mouse equivalent of
katruda
doesn't do anything to alleviate the
cancers in these
cd2 this city 26 model however
if we use uh k2d equivalent
with the sub-optimal concentration of
our peptide
we get 90 cures and obviously if we use
it with
the high concentration of uh the high
amount of our compound
we're more or less at the same level
we're pretty much maxed out on how much
we can do
and this is just here a presentation of
a couple my representation of what we
see
and the really exciting thing uh for us
was that
we waited for these uh mice that
were cured of their tumors we had 22 in
this trial we had around 22 mice
that were fully cured of their tumor
with one treatment of uh
our compound we waited for a couple of
months and then we decided to check
whether these mice have built an immune
memory
against uh this particular tumor
so we rechallenged uh all of these mice
with uh the same type of cancer cells
and as you can see here every single
mouse that got re-challenged
rejected the tumor you can see that some
of the mice clearly
did take the tumor it grew for a little
bit but
the immune system kicked in and cleared
it out fully
so what that tells us is that uh
yeah 22 out of 22 challenged mice
fully regressed their tumors and
it's telling us that there is some sort
of a memory that happens but just to
confirm it to ourselves
we decided to compare the rescue that we
see in the
immune proficient mass the balp cmos
against
an immunocompromised version of that
mouse model
and for that we relied on natsuki gamma
chain
mice and sg mice in there when we
implanted tumors treat them same way
with pbs
the cancers take
take off very fast and
within a short period of time they get
to very high volumes
then in in these mice that are
immunocompromised when we treat them
with a single dose
high dose of our compound we still
manage to cure one out of eight mice but
the majority of the mice
some of them experience some delay but
what we think is happening there is that
uh that single treatment of our compound
kills
50 60 90 of the cancer cells
in the one lucky mouse basically with 99
of the most of the cells there so they
didn't have a way of coming back up
but then in the other treated mice maybe
we didn't kill all of the cancer cells
at once in that single dose
and the remaining cells basically
because they didn't activate an immune
response because there is no immune
response in these mice
eventually came back and the tumor came
back so the one thing to note obviously
is yeah there is a delay in the tumor
volume but eventually once it takes off
it takes off
and that's very consistent with us
having been able to kill a lot of the
cells first
but we didn't get engagement on the
immune system
so to summarize all this what we think
our compound is doing is that it
has a cell intrinsic activity on the
cancer cells such a toxic cell intrinsic
activity
by uh exploiting the high amounts of
blood 51 inside the cancer cells
we're releasing that calcium out of that
51 the cancer cells
and that kills the majority of the cells
but those cells that do die
they don't just die they actually die
and
present a lot of immunogenic markers on
their surface
and that leads to the uh professional
antigen presenting cells
to come up and gobble them up quickly
and present them to the immune system to
t cells
to train the immune system to actually
have a memory against the neo antigens
that are present in these cancer cells
and have a
prolonged response against those tumors
and curative response
against those tumors so this is in a
nutshell the program the rafter t1
program it's
triggering a novel immunogenic cell that
kills cells in a very quick way
but doesn't just kill cells it also
engages the immune system
our medicinal chemistry efforts led us
to having
developing a compound that's very stable
and
uh a compound that allowed us to do a
lot of nvivo work
and our activity the activity of our
compound can turn
very cold immune checkpoint called
tumors
that are refractory to treatment with
opdivo
quetruda or any of these types of
checkpoint blockade inhibitors
therapies we can sensitize
these cells with a single treatment with
our compound
and the ongoing studies right now are
the second generation version of this
compound that allows us to do systemic
administration of the compound
and also deep understanding of the
mechanism of action
the immunological mechanism of action of
how we turn cold tumors into hot
in response to treatment with scx100
today i've had the time to talk about
rat51 i know
um fast time i think uh so i'll
we i just i want to share with you that
we also have a
oncogenic keras program as i said in the
beginning we have a couple of other
programs
we are very excited about the power and
strength of our platforms
in the new biology that they allow us to
discover and
from here i'll take any questions you
have thank you
so for those of you who are still with
us um if you could
keep sending questions in if we can't
get to them
during our normal scheduled programming
run here
we will certainly um answer them
afterwards because charlie and i will be
available right after the talk
um in the excuse me in the networking
lounge
and we can continue to answer questions
there
um charlie assuming that you can hear me
could i ask you just a couple of
questions
of course so um
[Music]
i am i'm i'm very very taken by the um
by the fact that um in your
um c26 colon model um
and actually i should i should preface
this by asking
uh so were these were these um
were these tumors um generated from
um from a single flank injection of
tumor cells
yeah they were yes and so with the
was as far as treatment was was
concerned
were those uh intra-tumor injections or
us um or dermal
no they were actually intra-tumor
injections
it's particularly because the peptides
tend to have a very short half-life
we've managed to stabilize the peptide
and make it very proteolytically stable
right when we do systemic administration
of the peptide uh it clears very fast
through renal clearance basically even
the the
peptide remains impacted just it clears
to the kidneys and
and to avoid having any issues of
pharmaceutical
property weaknesses that prevent
efficacy we decided to go the
tumor route just to probe the biology
first and understand what
uh what happens when tumors inside an
animal gets exposed
directly to the treatment right so
so given that then it's it's it's
actually even more remarkable
um seeing that the that you know the the
the heterogeneity that you find in a
tumor
regardless of whether i think the you
know you you have a
a single ostensibly single clone of
cells
of cells going in and to to develop a
tumor
the uptake then of the peptide if
clearing is fast the uptake of the
peptide must be
must be remarkably fast um
and
[Music]
the the the the therapeutic effect of
the peptide then
um even though you may not you even
though you may not see
a um you know a a decrease in
tumor volume occurring
for a certain number of days um
as i say the uptick must be must be must
be remarkably fast
and to virtually
virtually all cells in the tumor
yeah that's pretty much what was so
impressive to us that
we are seeing inside the animal what we
see in the dish
that yeah the peptide is being able to
enter into the cells within a couple of
minutes so obviously the scarring around
the tumor that the cells die of the
square
is still there so we don't necessarily
see a
resorption of the tumor within the first
couple of days but
uh we do clearly see that it never grows
back up and
it yeah i mean i agree i don't think
that the
whatever leftover of the peptide that
was injected that didn't get taken up by
the cancer cells in the first few
minutes
and first half hour let's say uh is
is not going just once i'm being asked
the amount of peptide that stays in the
mouse and the systemically
in the mouse after the first half hour
or an hour is very very little
so whatever it doesn't go in within the
first half hour is not going to
mean whatever cells did not take up the
peptide within the first half hour
i'm not going to take it because it's a
single single treatment
and and yeah so that that to us like
what we saw with the natsuki gamma chain
knockout mice uh is that we do see a
strong delay
and there's one mouse that completely
got cured in the absence of an immune
system
presumably as i said in the talk there
because maybe in that particular tumor
every single cell where the 90 or 95
of the cells in the in that tumor that
was implanted
they took up the peptide from that
single injection and got killed by it
and then there was no need to engage an
immune system to to
get rid of all of it while the other
tumors in
nsg mice they experienced a very
prolonged delay in tumor volume takeoff
but eventually they took off like after
a week which to us suggests that like
we've killed the majority of the cells
in that tumor when we got the antitone
injection
but then there were a few escapers that
didn't take up the pump it's not that
they're resistant to the peptide they
just didn't take up the peptide before
it cleared
and and those obviously now there's no
immune system and there is no
peptide around so they're going to take
off and keep going
and the health in in the immune
proficient mice
the the the same phenomenon is happening
in like that
window of time that they when they take
the peptide
they're going a lot of the cells are
going to be cytotoxically killed by the
intrinsic activity the cancer intrinsic
activity of the peptide
but then what what happens next is that
dendritic cells and macrophages come in
uh
basically to clear those dying cells in
the process they're presenting their
proteins
to the immune system and having uh
basically building
like a vaccinating the the mouse against
that particular tumor
and what we see also uh so obviously we
didn't just uh
rely on the cd26 colon cancer model
we've done
uh mammary tumors 41
the 41 model melanomas b16 f10 model
these are very difficult and one thing
we
consistently so we see activity against
all of them but
there's a very clear consistent
correlation between
the number the known number of neo
antigens
in the cancer line
like for example ct-26s are known to
have around 2000 new antigens
uh relative to a cd1
or abc mouse uh the p16s have much less
than that like
maybe 500 400 540 ones are
single or double digit type numbers very
small numbers
so that the less new antigens the tumor
[Music]
has the
weaker response we get we do get
responses from all of them but it's
harder to get the
the immune system engaging with the
tumors that have
less uh new antigens right right
so i think we have i did um so i do have
an
another couple of questions but let's
let's um i'll i'll hold those until we
get to
to the uh networking room um
so as far as um as far as our time in
the presentation is concerned
uh right now we'll wrap it up and um
excuse me thank you very much for those
of you um who have attended
and um i hope you can join us in the
networking room um
for at least another say five or ten
minutes so we can we can um
chat some more and and potentially um
answer additional questions so thank you
very much